[Applaudissements]
suivre heureuse d'être ici avec vous
j'étudie la psychologie sociale des
relations à autrui
je suis contente de partager avec vous
ça que j'ai découvert combien d'entre
vous ont une relation amoureuse explorer
à l'intérieur de vous même vous est il
déjà arrivé de vous sentir obligés de
faire quelque chose pour autrui
éventuellement pour votre partenaire ne
vous inquiétez du regard qu'on portait
sur vous se voir à travers le regard des
autres peuvent être exaltant mais peut
aussi être destructeur c'est un outil de
contrôle beaucoup plus puissant est
fréquent qu'on ne le pense si des
personnes parmi vous dans cette salle
ont déjà vécu ça sachez que vous n'êtes
pas seuls
votre voix et votre regard sont un super
pouvoir aux sentiments sont légitimes et
vos actions peuvent changer le monde
je vais vous faire une confidence moi
j'ai vécu sous le regard d'autrui et
j'ai failli y laisser ma vie je vais
vous dire comment ça se passe et aussi
comment reprendre votre pouvoir d'agir
il y a quelques années j'ai rencontré un
homme qui semble être merveilleux -
réfugié en france d'un pays totalitaire
de l'europe de l'est sont des ans
m'impressionnait c'était quelqu'un d'une
intelligence brillante quelqu'un qui
inspirait la sympathie qui était sûr de
soi qui avait l'art de convaincre
il m'a fait découvrir ses auteurs
préférés qui stimule la réflexion
il m'a présenté à ses amis à sa famille
ils me traitaient comme une princesse
petit à petit j'en suis tombée amoureuse
alors c'est vrai il décrivait son ex
comme étant folle je me suis dit que
c'était un danger qui ne m'a menacé pas
nous avions tous deux des enfants il
s'entendait bien nous avons emménagé
ensemble
deux ans plus tard on s'est mariés sous
le soleil de l'italie
autant vous dire au paradis sur terre et
j'étais prête à vivre le compte de fait
qui s'annonçait en fait que nous avons
emménagé ensemble
il a commencé à critiquer ma façon de
m'habiller le travail des levées ma
fille mais comme il disait que c'était
pour m'améliorer je lui trouvais mille
excuses je faisais tout pour devenir à
ses yeux les pouces parfaite et quoi que
je fasse ce n'était jamais assez bien à
ses yeux
progressivement ces remarques sont
devenus de plus en plus fréquente des
critiques des humiliations une torture
il a fini par contrôler mes horaires de
travail et mon agenda électronique
quand j'étais enceinte il me disait que
j'étais moche que ma voix était moche
que j'étais une logique que je devais
avoir compte ces mollahs ont colonisé
mon cerveau c'était sa télécommande
contrôle sur moi
à force je ne savais plus qui j'étais je
disais merci et pardon à tout le monde
lorsque je pensais que je ne méritait
même pas que les gens me disent bonjour
rétréci par la honte c'était facile de
m'isoler petit à petit je suis devenue
muette pour ne pas déclencher ses
colères parce qu'elles finissent mal
quand j'ai repris mon travail à
l'université je vais tellement
intériorisé son regard sur moi que j'ai
fini par me terrer dans mon bureau est
fermé la porte à clé de l'intérieur pour
pas que les autres voient mes collègues
ma laideur aucun regard amis pour tirer
la lame
surtout que pendant toutes ces années
j'ai continuer à m'occuper de mes filles
dont bien que mal de mes recherches
scientifiques et en même temps j'étais
terrorisée quand j'entendais le déclic
de sa clé dans la porte
mais quand il me prenait la main en
public
l'illusion du conte de faits étaient
parfaites aux yeux de tous moi j'avance
est comme une zombie sous emprise sous
son emprise
j'étais terrorisée que tout ce que
j'avais construit s'écroulait terrorisé
aussi que si je partais ils allaient se
venger ça allait empirer que j'allais me
retrouver avec mes filles à la rue ces
mots étaient devenus les barreaux de la
prison et son regard les projectiles qui
ment réduite à moins que rien le jour où
j'ai pris conscience où j'ai réagi c'est
grâce à mes filles ma grande à 17 ans et
l'a vu clair je n'oublierai jamais son
regard quand elle m'a dit maman
il faut partir nous sommes réfugiés dans
un petit 30 mètres carrés et là l'impact
psychotraumatiques a été énorme
j'ai tout perdu ma dignité des pousses
de mer deux chercheuses d'êtres humains
je n'avais plus rien sauf mes filles à
nourrir à soutenir et à l'école
à cette époque j'ai dû lire une quantité
de livres équivalente à tout ce que
j'avais vu dans ma thèse
c'était des lectures sur l'autre main
j'ai découvert le travail de chercheuse
qui s'appelle judith herman et qui est
la spécialiste mondial du trauma herman
a analysé des milliers de cas de trauma
allant de la guerre à l'emprisonnement
aux camps de concentration et
d'extermination nazis aux abus sur les
enfants aux violences au sein du couple
elle a trouvé que dans toutes ces
situations de captivité par le contrôle
qu'il prenait sur elle l'auteur des abus
devenait la personne la plus puissante
de la vie de la victime et que la
psychologie de la victime était
entièrement façonnée par les actions et
les croyances de l'auteur alors quand
j'ai vu ça un matin après une énième lui
d'insomnie je me suis dit plus jamais
cet homme ne contrôlera plus jamais il
ne fera du mal à mes filles et j'ai
réalisé que pour leur donner à elle une
vie digne
il fallait que je me retrouve moi même
or j'étais seul pendant toutes ces
années il avait réussi à isoler alors
qu'est ce que j'ai fait mille choses
mais je vous admire 3 la première c'est
que j'ai réuni une spécialiste une
équipe de spécialistes d'élite qui ont
cru en moi plus que moi même pendant
deux ans j'ai vécu de leur confiance et
de celle de mes filles la deuxième c'est
que je les ai vus chaque semaine je me
suis rassembler pièce par pièce
j'ai étudié les mécanismes de sortie de
l'emprise j'ai repris mon activité
physique un repos une nutrition saine je
rééquilibre à ma charge de travail
la troisième c'est que j'ai investi en
moi même j'ai mis trois ans pour me
relever
j'ai mis en place un programme mentale
et d'action pour me relever jour après
jour
j'ai combattu l'impact dévastateur du
psycho trauma jour après jour j'ai
failli y laisser ma vie
mais jour après jour j'ai désintoxiquer
mon cerveau et jour après jour j'ai
retrouvé courage confiance et clarté si
vous vous êtes senti intimidé par le
regard d'autrui
si vous l'avez vécu ces derniers mois c
est ceux d'entre vous qui l'ont vécue il
ya des années celles et ceux d'entre
vous qui le vivent aujourd'hui je suis
là pour vous dire que je ne serai pas la
femme que je suis si je n'avais pas
appris tout cela demain survie et que
vous aussi si vous êtes prêt investiront
vous même un jour vous serez là à ma
place à dire aux autres comment vous
avez fait cette expérience a façonné ma
vision et transformer totalement mon
travail j'ai eu la chance de faire une
thèse en psychologie sociale avec un
mentor un penseur immense serge
moscovitch serge moscovitch a survécu au
programme en europe de l'est et il a été
un réfugié en france à l'âge de certains
d'entre vous 22 ans je vous recommande
d'ailleurs son livre mais année après
guerre à paris non seulement parce qu'il
est papa d'un c'est très bien comme vous
mais ça va vous inspirer et sérieusement
scoville s'intéresser aux changements
c'est celui qui a donné la parole aux
marginaux qui a saisi l'impact de la
parole des marginaux et marginaux ou le
sont toutes
nous le sommes tous quand nous parlons
vrai à contre courant des autres qu'on
nous lisons une autre vérité
il nous disait que dans l'histoire des
sociétés les grands changements arrivent
souvent par les hordes cider par les
désobéissants par les groupes extérieurs
au courant dominant il étudiait les
luttes féministes et le civil rights
movement
c'est les luttes des afro américains
pour en finir avec la dsna avec la
ségrégation raciale
comment avait-elle pu émerger et
transformer la société en profondeur
alors qu'elles étaient minoritaires et
n'avait ni l'autorité ni la confiance
des majorités ces recherches ont montré
que le changement a lieu parce qu'une
minorité déclenché un processus de
conversion des autres à son point de vue
cette conversion est capable de
transformer les perceptions profonde des
sociétés
et vous savez quel est le grand tournant
de ce changement
il est à l'intérieur même des personnes
c'est ce moment précis où elle qu'on a
traitées comme marginal par rapport au
code social dans notre pays dominants se
revendique comme minorité active
affirment leurs propres codes et le
propose aux autres comme alternative à
l'or d'objets d'autrui elles deviennent
sujets d'elle-même dans mon cas ce
processus a pris trois ans les
mouvements antiracistes avance sur des
dizaines d'années les féministes les
féministes ont fait bouger les lignes
depuis des décennies on est sur des
temporalités longue mais à force
l'investissement de visibilité
d'autonomie de persévérance on peut
changer le monde
oser être soi c'est déjà faire changer
les autres
c'est ce que font les minorités actives
affirmé qu'ils nous sommes osé se lever
oser dire non ça change la vie de
quiconque s'est sentie dominé par le
regard d'autrui
et je peux vous le dire quand vous le
faites vous vous retrouvez vous même
vous rayonnez de l'intérieur oser être
soi aux et s'exposer regard des autres
quand nous sommes capables de le faire
tel que nous sommes la chercheuse
brownie brown qui est spécialiste de la
ville d'hama vulnérabilité pense que
nous sommes capables de mieux nous
connecter aux autres nous osons plus et
nous menons des vies plus heureuse et je
voudrais conclure en disant que prendre
la parole à dire qui nous sommes
affirmer nos ambitions comme notre main
à un coût personnel très élevé c'est
terrifiant et ça fait peur et ça change
la vie à jamais mais je crois
profondément que c'est la bonne chose à
faire parce que ça permet aux autres de
savoir que quelqu'un d'autre
avant soit a traversé les mêmes
obstacles
et qu'on s'en sort mon psy qu'aux
traumatismes ne guérira pas et ne
disparaîtra jamais mais bien soutenu on
en ressort grandi
notre monde se remet à l'endroit on
réapprend à rester debout face aux
pressions des autres connecter à notre
propre vision de nous-mêmes et on
atteint une clarté de vie fabuleuse
fabuleuse sur la valeur des priorités
qui mérite notre énergie et notre
persévérance
combien même on est attaqué de toutes
parts et ça ça ça nous concerne tous
j'ai mis en place un programme mentale
et d'actions pour les personnes qui
comme moi portent l'empreinte du regard
des autres
basé sur les recherches en psychologie
en médecine en neurosciences conçu avec
les meilleurs spécialistes et testé dans
les conditions extrêmes que j'ai vécu
c'est un programme que vous pouvez
appliquer à la gestion de votre santé et
votre objectif
osez vous lever pour ceux qui vous tient
à coeur pour ce qui compte pour vous
pour rayonner
rappelez-vous oser être soi c'est déjà
commencer à transformer les autres dans
ce programme le premier pas est simple
et décisif et je vous invite à le faire
penser à une cause qui vous tient à
coeur
rappelez vous pourquoi
hélas un sens profond pour vous si vous
y croyez
foncez parlez-en avec votre voix et
votre vision c'est un super pouvoir
c'est votre super pouvoirs rappelez-vous
oser être soi c'est déjà commencer à
transformer les autres et je voudrais
finir par cette célèbre phrase d'un
penseur qui s'appelle ville elle qui est
l'un des penseurs les plus marquants de
l'histoire de l'humanité qui disait si
je ne suis pas pour moi même qui le sera
et si je ne suis qu pour moi
qui suis-je et si pas maintenant alors
quand merci
[Applaudissements]